yeah welcome to this video yeah this is
something that I haven't done for a
while a book review yeah and recently
when I did those live streams for a sec
and sometimes got questions what kind of
books can you recommend sometimes it was
a specific question what is your
favorite book things like that but also
in this era book that recently was
released that you were impressed with
and I think I mentioned more than one
time I mentioned this new book by Victor
Borge on bull against black weapons yeah
in the open games it's the complete
title of bolo guns black weapons in the
open games how to play for win of white
avoids the reuleaux pests so this is a
black repertoire book form players who
answer efore with money five double King
pawn if you know my video was my blitz
games you know that one e5 is my main
move against f1 and yeah I have to deal
with those things so this is a book that
definitely interests me personally and I
was really impressed with it so I'm
going to show you a little bit more
about this book if you intend to play
one if for money five is black while you
already do and feel like your repertoire
needs some refreshing some updates or
simply some more solid ground then this
book is definitely for you to get I'm
here on the new inch s website which is
a new chest as a publisher for this book
and this is also may I recommend that
you go to look at those sample pages
yeah what I will do now I will show you
some sample pages of this book I
meantime I got it I got it myself but
some sample pages too for you to get an
impression you can of course go to the
website and do this yourself so let's
have a look at those sample pages the
sample pages Adams gather contents and I
will show you some things some things
later and I'll also give you an overview
about the repertoire presented when we
actually will put up a chessboard and I
will show you some lines but it is a
very comprehensive
overview if you look at the page count
300 380 400 400 something and it ends
with 500 something pages so it's a 500
page thick book it's really quite quite
massive this book yeah and it's really
really nicely done why is it such a
massive book the reason is that below
Gong didn't present just one line
against every main system but more more
than more often than not it presents two
or even three options for black and this
is a thing a good thing because it's not
like every option is the right one for
every occasion or for every player
sometimes you rather prefer somewhat
calm game sometimes you want to sharpen
it up while sometimes you really want to
avoid any theoretical workload and it
tries to do that for every variation the
book also contains something that I
really like okay we have an introduction
yeah and lots of interesting information
but it also yeah it gives an overview
about how the book is structured
I can answer I can show you right yeah
actually what is the book doing there
are many interesting things ever look
here this is one thing that is very
interesting there are game references
not in the text but done with those
little small numbers here references and
at the end of each chapter you get a get
a list of all the reference games this
is something that is a matter of taste
but I think it's an interesting approach
so there's no nothing in the in the text
like this was played in game so-and-so
but in game seven and then you have to
look at what what Game seven actually
means sometimes this is a bit annoying
that you have to switch to the to the
appendix but it makes the whole thing a
little bit more readable it's it's an
interesting approach I have for once I'm
not so interested in who
we played those those games I can look
this up in the database I'm more
interested about the author's opinion of
him about a certain move from online he
also has this kind of thing where if you
have a reference number with a square
around and then it's a new move so
interesting it also shows alternatives
like here's an alternative or here's an
alternative and every chapter but and
this we probably should do with an
example here this is also very
interesting he has two approaches for
the chapters the fast lane and the very
fast lane this is interesting yeah
so every chapter has a sort of summary
where he says okay the very fast lane
means you want to look at this line what
is the most essential thing that you
look at first so if you really have
little time on your hands or do you want
to get an idea what's happening in a
specific line then the very fast lane is
where to start there's also the fast
lane which is a little bit more
comprehensive a little bit longer and
takes more time to learn but it's a nice
way to summarize the these chapters and
make it easier to access I think it's a
it's a quite good idea to do that
yeah gambits a couple of gambit some and
then a very very nice feature of this
book the arsenal of strategic ideas and
themes we can look at this how it looks
like this is the Arsenal and yeah what
he does is he shows on about 30 to 40
pages I think he gives an overview about
central pawn structures ideas yeah what
happens in what structure what are the
ideas what other palm breaks or peace
manoeuvres yeah how are pieces plays and
so on and very interesting overview and
it is it's doing one thing those things
are also mentioned in them in the actual
chapters but it does one interesting
thing let me give you an exam
here something like that
he attaches certain names to structures
sometimes those names are well-known
sometimes they are not this for example
the nihms own nightmares a very very
funny name below Gong calls this
structure here the nihms own nightmare I
don't want to get into details why it
should be a nightmare or whatever but
it's very interesting if you attach
those kind of catchy names to third
structures it helps you to to to
remember the features yeah the names of
nightmares something that sticks into
your mind and maybe it helps you to
avoid this position he says that for
example some of those structures are a
little bit problematic for black depends
on certain features of the position and
this is why nightmare and so on and this
helps you to to remember things better
if you have a name attached to it I also
learned that the my favorite move Queen
h4 I have to look it up Queen h4 in the
open games has it has a name actually
let me have a look after really curious
now what what the name was I forgot it
actually I braised it it has a funny
name Staunton screen yeah stones Queen
Queen h4 a Stalin's Queen yeah so this
is what I was talking about he gives a
good overview about strategic features
of the position yeah this is how a
normal chapter looks like it starts with
the Fastlane and this is really a
pragmatic approach it's very interesting
here for example we have a something
about the rare 3rd moves which means the
very off beat stuff that white can do
one move three if you look at this here
in this diagram this is the stuff like
d3 or b3 or Bishop b2 and what he says
is save your energy and go to the next
chapter you rarely see this opening some
yeah
it won't happen that off now this kind
of opening and it's not very dangerous
this is a good information you know
frankly speaking I never looked at three
Bishop b2 or d3 why should you you can
just
one of your pieces so it is good to have
an overview because there are some ideas
related to those moves but really it's
not theoretically very critical so skip
your energy good advice
let's scroll a little bit more it's this
chapter is CM and here this is good at
the end of each chapter gives an
overview about the traps though there
are often traps related to openings even
some openings that are not that
dangerous but there might be a little
trap in there so he wants you about
those he gives you information about
transpositions and move orders yeah here
it's not that tricky but sometimes move
order is important in e45 openings there
are some move all the issues not that
much as in in close games but some some
move all the problems are definitely an
yeah to be avoided the antia key idea is
to remember the f7 f5 leave Amanda Milan
nukes break line be - I don't even know
what that is so maybe I can learn
something here Milan nukes break what is
this I think it's a 5 a 4 against B 3
and this in this structure yeah so this
is the kind of structure that this book
has also note how beautifully it is done
here this kind of markers for the pieces
I think it's really nicely layout in
book it really looks nice very it's a
very um yeah very solid production
values let's say this is the Ponciano
opening right that we had we got him
yeah this is how this this book looks
and yeah oh yeah
for this the fast lane line A to B is
one of the refutation of the how its
attack here and how its attack is Bishop
b5 in the Pantheon e line b2b offers
black a chance to outplay white okay so
this is a very brief
yeah summary what happens in the in the
upcoming chapters and he shows what
lines are the most important to know
that's really good you know I'm I
already like this approach to be honest
when I'm working on my book still and
I'm in the
process of finishing it my own book and
I had a similar idea I didn't call it
the Fastlane and so on but what I'm
doing is I'm writing a chapter
introduction for everything where I will
briefly try to summarize what lines yeah
how how much effort do you have to
invest to learn specific lines and I
often also give two possibilities one
that it's easier to learn one is a bit
more work to work to learn so I have a
similar idea but it is done very nicely
with this Fastlane very fast lane
approach so this is how this book yeah
looks like it's a it feels like yes
something of value very nice okay I will
also give you an overview about some of
the lines that are presented and of
course I need a chessboard for that so
just bear with me while I put up a board
so we've got a board now so I can give
you an overview about the presented
repertoire yeah as mentioned it is not
the case that he only gives one line
against each wide option but rather yeah
a selection of ideas and lines to choose
from it's a really big book so I'm going
to go through everything
the video should be yeah not like an
hour or two hours long if we start with
the rare stuff here in the very rare
lines this is all fairly standard he
gives some F we if we start there is a
center game but this kind of thing here
he gives both bishop be form I mean we
started with this just kind of normal to
give both this move and Bishop e7
they're both fine and it's a nice
selection to have him the Danish gambit
interesting we go back here the Danish
gambit which is this here he gives two
lines very good that that he mentions
two lines because the main line is d5
the the declined
and this often leads to this kind of
position which is surprisingly difficult
for black to win it's a long endgame
line which he also gives leading to
equal play but it's very difficult to
win this however if you want to play for
win he gives Queen e7 which is a very
good thing actually it wins the e4 pawn
and it looks a little bit strange but it
is strong it wins this pawn for a very
little compensation I actually think
that this move order here with d4 C 3 is
incorrect black is a pawn of him for
basically nothing Queen e7 is very
strong but he gives d5 as the solid
alternative because you have to know it
in a way anyway because oops not this
there is this month order after which d5
is well very valid and here Queenie 7
does not make much sense so this is why
d5 is an extra option given yeah there's
the bishops opening with Bishop c4 after
which Knight f6 is played and yeah we
have transpositions to this of course
which maybe it's more likely or should
be classified as a vienna game he gives
this line and also knight c6 intending
Knight a5 so that's a huge variety of
lines to choose from according to your
taste and your yeah your idea for this
game let's say sometimes you want to be
a little bit sharp and sometimes a
little bit more solid here also this is
nice he gives both this was the total
main line in also knight c6 quite
interesting that both has mentioned it
there are some subtle differences here
regards to various setups for example if
white plays g3 this kind of quiet setup
here black has additional options with
f5 or h5 not this one that looks strange
h5 f5 however as this main idea to play
him and also if white intends to play
the Vienna with f4 then here you have
additional very aggressive
actions which he also discusses so in
the in the rare lines there's this
really nice overview of lines okay let's
go back the Kings gambit yeah the Kings
gambit he has two lines against the
Kings gambit and this is really really
important because the Kings gambit is a
relatively rare opening I have gotten it
on the board once in 10 years of Kings
gambit and 10 years of a 45 is black and
if you learn super sharp line you never
get it on the board and then when you
get it you have forgotten it so he gives
a relatively low maintenance line and a
sharp line this of course is the sharp
line and this is also probably the best
line against the Kings gambit he is
however giving against this move it's
not giving very interesting it's not
giving Bishop g7 like everybody plays
nowadays but even g4 to actually accept
espy sacrifice he thinks that this is
good for black yeah I personally
wouldn't play this even if it is good
but just as my personal preference I
don't like to be attacked that much but
if you don't like this kind of super
sharp approach he also gives them this
line on to be more precise this line the
modern defends to the King's gambit
which is also what I had chosen for my a
45 repertoire in my video series for the
channel this is the no-nonsense approach
black just develops normally and this is
something that you can play without much
theoretical workload it's the the simple
approach what else let's have a look
rare third ins after this what do we
have here the Pantheon II against the
Ponciano he gives two lines the line
that I gave in my my video 65 which is
just frankly speaking probably the best
move
and leads to an easy game for black
sometimes even an advantage if widest
playing bad lines or he gives this move
and after D for the capture which is
very interesting that's a good line to
have in your repertoire also because
there is this gambit line which I
briefly had shown beforehand I mentioned
that this is a good reply but a little
bit boring and this also gives you this
move as an alternative it's just a funny
transposition the Ponzi on E and the
Goren gambit I am actually transposing
into one another that's also this gambit
approach here in this zone this overview
and yeah he gives Bishop c5 is good and
yeah of course just this and also Knight
f6 Wichitans poses to the two knights
this is not really very dangerous
then the Scotch opening which is really
important the Scotch is one of the one
of the the main alternatives to the ruin
opus and the good thing is he gives a
really a boatload of lines the knight of
six line and the Bishop c5 line really
nice so both are covered and you can
choose from what you like very nice and
also even with sub variations and here
he's given in the four Knights Scotch is
giving both the classical move enter now
I'm not sure if you would call it a
modern move but the a little bit
slightly offbeat move Bishop c5 very
nice that you have both them both lands
covered also what I liked is that after
this this he gave her Queen f6 which is
of course the main line but he also gave
this rare move which are find
interesting this is slightly related to
what I play against the Scotch I have
this this funny line they endured the
check and then I go here and after this
I have to take and this is quite related
very interesting coverage in the book so
it's I think it's really nice that you
have this this selection of lines an
interesting point is that him
I'm sorry of course not 9527 2295 see
for that he I am exclusively gives
Knight b6
there's also Bishop a6 but okay then you
have to cut something short yeah you
cannot show all lines but Knight b6 is
of course a good and reliable line and
in fact the coverage in the book and
probably will lead to to me looking at
this a little bit more and play this is
black I really wanted an alternative to
my check all the time so that at least
can vary a little bit I mean I know some
of that but not really well um what else
is there the four Knights you know the
four Knights this opening he gives some
interesting things against g3 the Glac
system both this and d5 is good and he
shows both options there is the world
where is it
yeah the Spanish for Knights yeah this
is a slightly annoying opening is black
if you want to play for win because
there are many varied raw edge lines 94
for example it's the theoretically
recommended move but it has one drawback
white can play this which leads to a
totally dull position yeah there is this
kind of thing happening where at the end
well we're all Knights are traded and
it's very symmetrical and boring and
yeah this is this is very good about
this book is very practical and says
okay you know this is good 94 but it's
only really good if you if you want to
play for win well 94 is a drawback if
white just won the draw I can get it
with ninety 64 with good player and TM
presents an alternative that you can
play if you really really really want to
win and this is Bishop d6 looks a little
bit strange I know but this is an F
the good move black wants to castle I
give you an example something something
like that is blacks idea and then back
to evade this happens quite often in
their open games the Sun this idea the
bishop is normally coming from c5 of 47
Bishop d6 is a totally respectable line
I know it looks kind of strange but it's
not that bad I have played it myself
already in cases where I wanted to play
for win but if this looks too weird to
you he gives Bishop b4 as an alternative
to play em anymore
yeah harmonious fashion maybe this is
also a little bit dull but ok for the
people who want to get a fight we should
be six as the the better move yeah a big
part of the book of course is Bishop C
form the Italian game and he gives both
knight f6 and Bishop c5 and this is
really great because Bishop c5 and 9 f6
are really somewhat different in regards
to to various things for example after
Bishop c5 White has the Evans gambit not
everybody's cup of tea to be confronted
with this gambit but you also have some
relatively dull lines like this where
it's not that easy to play for a win he
covers all that and black is totally
fine sometimes it's a little bit boring
and friendly speaking I also find some
lines of the Italian game rather boring
like like this with d3 where white very
often goes for trades and so on and this
is nice that he also covers Knight f6
because this is just more aggressive it
puts a question to the four point
immediately and well white has to react
to that he cannot play c3 d4 anymore the
other has to play d3 now to cover the
pawn except equality like with this or
ninety five which leads to gambit
playoff mania gives the main line which
is the most reliable one and I think
this is the first coverage of this
gambit lines for a long time on a decent
level I mean there was some book some
years ago about this line but
I mean if the books are like eight years
or ten years old they are mostly not
engine checked and this is of course
very valuable in nowadays that this
modern books that had done yeah in a
decent way they are all checked with
computers so especially in sharp
positions you can be much more confident
that this is technically sound so very
nice overview here he also gives after
d3 there's of course the transposition
to the Italian which is mentioned a
little bit doubt but very solid but also
this move which is nice because well if
you want to play for winning sometimes
the more passive looking move Bishop is
seven is a little bit better even
because it avoids trade after Bishop c5
Bishop III for example and Bishop e7
keeps all pieces on the board yeah it's
in a way a little bit more of a fighting
move and it also has the idea to to put
up something like this in the right move
on I'm not sure if this is a correct one
actually I could look it up but this is
a totally different approach to the
Bishop c5 Italian game now so that both
options he are covered is very nice
there's also good coverage about those
wacky gambit lines that there I am this
for example is totally fine for black
but you have to to know what you're
doing
he gives an interesting of things in the
Evans gambit by the way which I never
knew even existed he gives this for
example Bishop a5 let me look at after
they have to look this up because I
really never saw this before let me look
against before I think let me let me
check this is really funny what is he
giving isn't this b5 yes he gives b5 huh
what a crazy move but it seems to be
okay
the Beckster variation yeah there are so
many so many forgotten lines and though
the idea is that after this you will
take on d4 with the knight
and you had to somehow misplace this
bishop first yeah I think because of a
bishop f7 yeah if you if you play em
play take it take it back play this
first white white probably will take
here and then get this have to get the
Bishop to b5 first strange stuff but
well it's really a funny thing if you
look at very old lines this is probably
from the from from 1800 something
sometimes you can dig out good all of
the old lines check them with modern
technology and they're quite often quite
quite okay you only have to refresh it
yeah get some some new ideas and support
some of those old things with new new
ideas and analysis yeah a really great
book if you are looking for something
about a 45s black this is the book to
get there are some other decent books
for black repertoire if white avoids
through no pest but I think this is
really the the best one out there and
the the really big advantage of this
book compared to other a45 repertoire
books no don't there's no rule no
peasant there's just anything everything
else a big advantage is that you very
often get two or three options to choose
from and this is I think very valuable
sometimes an opening books gives you
just just one specific line and if you
happen to dislike it well then you're
basically yeah then you need to look for
something else get another book analyze
yourself and tear at least I mean if you
don't like let's say if he presents two
or three options that you don't like any
of those then you probably should
reconsider this opening is for you
because then it's probably a case that
you don't like the general structure or
whatever so there should be something in
there for everyone and it's a good let's
say compromise between yeah being
comprehensive yeah and then show
everything and don't go into too much
detail should be a good
middle-of-the-road approach you don't
need 3,000 pages of opening theory
really don't it's just something
find the good a good good balance
between yeah being complete and show
what you need to know and especially
this Fastlane approaches is a very this
is very nice yeah I hope you enjoyed
this overview of really a really nice
book I will do some more opening reviews
and in the next couple of days one or
two at least because there are some
books that I really liked recently and
ya round Christmas time maybe you still
want to want to get yourself a present
or someone else so um some book
recommendation might come in handy
yeah I hope you liked it I'll be back
very soon with new videos also some new
cubed same content also I can announce
that during a Christmas time I will do
some live streams 1 2 or 3 I know I will
announce it on the channel thanks for
watching